hey 42 here lots of random odds and
ends get washed up on the beach
seashells
seaweed empty plastic bottles
driftwood the corpse of a welsh
dressed up to look like an officer of
the royal marines
okay so maybe that last one was a bit of
a curveball
but that's exactly what a spanish
fisherman found
near the port city of huelva in 1943
during the second world war of course it
isn't
unheard of for dead soldiers to wash up
on beaches
in times of war but this was no ordinary
corpse
and in discovering it the unwitting
fishermen
triggered the first step in a carefully
orchestrated chain of events
devised by the british secret service to
fool
adolf hitler into making a catastrophic
tactical blunder you see by this point
in the war the tide was already
beginning to turn in favor of the allies
the japanese attack on pearl harbor in
had convinced the united states to make
a timely appearance on the global
battlefield
the nazi invasion of the soviet union
was fast turning into an unmitigated
disaster
and the allies had just scored a
resounding victory
in the north african campaign but for
all this success
by early 1943 the nazis and daraxis
allies
still controlled most of europe
something that was going to need to be
rectified
if the war was to be won luckily with
the north african campaign concluded
the allies suddenly had huge numbers of
troops
in need of a new assignment the only
question was
what were they going to do with them
victory in africa
had opened up a whole new angle of
attack against the axis powers
and the allies planned to use it
there were two possible targets sicily
which would give the allies a foothold
in italy and
clear important shipping lanes in the
mediterranean
or greece allowing for a pincer movement
pressing the germans up against the
soviets on the eastern front
both options had their merits but as far
as the allies were concerned
only one really made sense invading
sicily
unfortunately sicily was such a juicy
target
hanging there like a big ripe
strategically important plum at the end
of italy's big
toe the axis powers were bound to
anticipate the attack
and concentrate their defenses
accordingly
which brings me back to our recently
deceased
welsh who also happens to be the
key
to operation mincemeat a stroke of
tactical deception
so ridiculous and bizarre the fact it
actually worked surprised everyone
not least to people who devised it the
aim of operation
mincemeat was simple convince hitler
as well as fellow fascism enthusiast
benito mussolini
and all the rest of the axis powers that
greece rather than sicily was the
ultimate destination for the allies
troops
in north africa but how exactly do you
go about
fooling the sharpest minds in the nazi
party
into thinking you're going to do one
thing when really
you're going to do the complete opposite
easy
you find a nice fresh corpse dress it up
to look like a british
royal marine shove a briefcase full of
fake
top secret documents into its cold dead
hands
then drop the corpse into the ocean wait
for it to get washed up
and discovered by german intelligence
and
finally hope they believe the fictional
invasion plans you've planted inside the
briefcase
are authentic okay so maybe
it's not that easy if all of this is
starting to sound like something
straight out of a james bond movie
then hey that's very perceptive of you
operation mincemeat was based in part
on a short document of creative military
deception techniques
called the trout memo which was
circulated by a man named admiral john
godfrey
but whilst godfrey took all the credit
for the ideas in the trout memo
most historians seem to agree the
document was
probably written by his assistant ian
fleming
who after the war would go on to write
the first bond novel whilst the trout
memo contains the central idea behind
operation mincemeat it didn't account
for all the
finer points of the plan like where to
get the body
how to create a plausible identity for a
man who never existed
or how to transport a corpse all the way
to spain
without being murdered by germans
intelligence officers
charles chumley yes weirdly that is how
you pronounce that
and you and montagu were tasked with
overcoming those little challenges
and the first thing on their checklist
was to obtain a corpse for the job at
hand
not only did the corpse have to be the
right age and gender
but the deceased also had to have died
recently
so as to be in a believable state of
decomposition when discovered
whilst plenty of young men died on a
regular basis
during the war it turns out most
families in mourning
want their loved ones laid to rest
respectfully
as opposed to dressed up in uniform and
tossed into the ocean upon their tragic
demise
which meant chumley and montagu would
ideally need to find a body with no
known relatives
under normal circumstances it might have
been almost impossible to find a
suitable stiff in such short notice
but this was wartime and unlike sugar
coal and nylon dead bodies were one of
the few commodities
not in short supply so chumley and
montagu
made a few discreet inquiries and
before long word of an appropriate body
reached their ears before becoming a
full-time corpse
that body had belonged to glyndor
michael
a welsh vagrant who'd tragically taken
his own life
by ingesting grat poison in an abandoned
warehouse in king's cross
glindor's body fit the bill perfectly
and with no family to notify of his
death
it was soon at the disposal of the
british secret service
of course obtaining a corpse was only
the first step in the mincemeat
plan before it could be dropped into
spanish waters
it needed a new identity so
chumley and montague set about
transforming
wells vagrant glindor michael into the
fictitious
major william martin distinguished
member
of the royal marines nothing could be
left a chance when attempting to deceive
high-ranking nazi officials so their
attention to detail
needed to be meticulous even major
william martin's name
and rank were carefully chosen he was
designated the official rank of
acting major as this made him senior
enough to be entrusted with top secret
documents
but not prominent enough that his name
or face would be known to the germans
the surname martin was chosen simply
because it was the most common name
amongst officers of the same rank
as for him being a royal marine that was
more a case of convenience
their uniforms were the easiest to
obtain
or at least that's what chumley and
montagu
thought until they encountered an
unexpected
uniform related problem as a
high-ranking member of the royal marines
major william martin would be expected
to be sporting a lovely pair
of woolen underpants any other kind
would raise suspicions the nazis may
have counted some of the most evil men
in history amongst their number
but apparently they really knew their
underpants
unfortunately such luxuries as woolen
drawers
were in very limited supply at the time
and no one was willing to part with
theirs
but this little issue was eventually
solved
by another recently deceased person a
college warden by the name of herbert
fisher
whose grieving family kindly donated a
pair of his old undies to the war effort
not only did major william martin need
to be dressed appropriately
he also needed to have a convincing
backstory
these days someone could have whipped up
a facebook page complete with
embarrassing junking photos of the
majors university days
in no time at all but back then they had
to be a bit more creative
chumley and montague started to curate a
collection
of what they like to refer to as pocket
litter
personal items and trinkets that would
make
major martin feel real things like
cigarettes
posted stamps matches keys
receipts and ticket stubs the major was
even given
a fictitious fiancee called pam who
existed in the form of two love letters
a receipt for a diamond engagement ring
and a rather saucy photograph
well for the time of pam drying herself
off with a beach towel
in reality pam was jean
and jean worked just down the corridor
it's mi5
of all the fake documentation needed to
bring major martin to life
the most important and problematic
was his naval id card the problem was
there were no photos of glindor michael
from his
pre-rat poison days attempts were made
to photograph the cadaver but michael
made a terrible model
he was far too stiff
[Music]
montague pondered over this little poser
for days before realizing the solution
to his problem
was staring him right in the face
literally
during a meeting at mi5 he found himself
sitting across from a man named ronnie
reed
who in montague's own words could have
been the twin brother of glindor michael
so reed's headshot was taken and the id
card was completed for added
authenticity
montague then spent the next few weeks
rubbing the card against his trouser leg
in order to give it an authentic warning
look
which was all the rage for id cards at
the time
chumley and montague finally had
everything they needed to set
operation mincemeat into action but
as the body was dressed and readied for
transportation
the pair hit another snag this time in
the form of major martin's military
boots
to keep the body preserved it had been
kept on ice for
several months but as i'm sure you're
aware
attempting to jam a pair of standard
issue military boots onto the feet of a
frozen corpse
is no mean feat and trying as they might
chumley and montagu couldn't manage it
luckily this little hurdle was overcome
relatively easily
the pair grabbed the nearest electrical
heater plugged it in
aimed at it the corpse's feet and forged
their mouse until they were just soft
enough
to slide the boots right into place and
you thought being a spy was glamorous
with his id card suitably worn a saucy
photograph of his fiancee in his pocket
and his military boots laced up glindor
michael
was now officially major william martin
of the royal marines leaving the secret
service to turn their attention to the
next stage of the plan
delivering the body into the hands of
the nazis
spain was chosen for the drop as it was
known to be rife with german spy
activity at the time
and the british knew a washed-up royal
marine
would soon have the nazis buzzing around
it like
flies around well a dead body
but simply dropping the corpse out of a
plane and into the ocean was far too
risky
people tend to notice things like
aeroplanes during world wars
and boats are also pretty conspicuous
this job called for something
a little more covert a submarine
called the hms seraph the seraph took
10 days to complete its journey to the
spanish coastline
after a day of reconnaissance the
submarine surfaced
and the body which had been preserved
inside a specially built container
was brought up to the deck and released
into the ocean
it was discovered only a few hours later
news soon reached the nazis who were
practically salivating at the prospect
of having a sneaky peek inside major
william martin's top secret briefcase
official procedures dictated that the
spanish authority should have sent the
briefcase straight back to the british
and they did but as had been predicted
first they allowed german spies to have
a gander at the goodies inside
we know this because when the secret
service inspected the documents after
their return to britain
a single eyelash which had been
carefully placed within the folds of one
of the letters
was noticeably absent the fictitious
plans
had been read by the enemy photographs
of the falsified documents ran up the
nazi command's chain
faster than you could do one of those
salutes that would get you arrested
today
and soon enough they found their way
into the hand of the fuhrer himself
he didn't doubt the authenticity of the
plans for one moment
in fact when benito mussolini tried to
convince him that it seemed
very likely the allies would focus their
attentions on sicily
not greece hitler simply refused to
listen
and he was adamant the spies had struck
gold
by intercepting genuine british military
plans
this blind belief in the authenticity of
the documents
might sound a little naive after all it
must have occurred to someone that the
documents could have been faked
but the deception went beyond just a
body and a briefcase
the whole ruse was supported by a large
number of pre-scripted diplomatic cables
exchanged between britain and spain in
which the british made it clear
how important it was that the briefcase
be recovered
and kept out of the hands of the nazis
the real genius here was that these
messages were all heavily encrypted
but the british knew the germans had
cracked their cipher
when the briefcase finally made it back
to blighty
a further series of messages was sent to
report the tests have been carried out
on the contents of the case confirming
they
hadn't been compromised this was a vital
step
as naturally the allies would have
changed their plans
if they had reason to believe the
germans had gotten wind of them
the complex deception was outrageously
successful
convinced he had gotten one over on the
allies
hitler gave orders for an entire panzer
division
of some 90 000 soldiers to be deployed
to a place britain had absolutely no
intention
of invading leaving the allies free to
invade sicily
with relative ease by the time hitler
realized his mistake it was too late
the successful invasion of sicily held
huge consequences for hitler and his
attempts at world domination
it paved the way for the allied invasion
of italy
and hastened mussolini's fall from power
and
in his desperation to regain control of
the mediterranean
hitler called off a huge planned
offensive against the soviet union
diverting one-fifth of the entire german
army
from the east to southern europe giving
the soviets a decisive advantage
in the battle for the eastern front if
the tides of war had been starting to
turn
when operation mincemeat was first
conceived
by the time the grand deception had
actually panned out
it isn't much of a stretch to suggest
the allies
were actually winning today operation
minsmith is regarded as one of the most
successful feats of deception
ever pulled off in the theater of war
the modern day equivalent of the trojan
horse
had the mission failed it's possible the
outcome of the war would have been very
different
and a lot more swastikery but what of
the real hero of the story
glindor michael the welsh vagrant who
died
twice to deceive the nazis a man who'd
felt his own life so insignificant
he decided to end it alone in a
warehouse in london
his body was buried in spain with full
military honors
for many years his tombstone only bore
the name of his fictional alter ego
the man who never was major william
martin
but in 1997 his real name was finally
added
to his resting place the great tragedy
of course
is that glindor michael will never know
how he
fooled hitler and changed the course of
history
in the process thank you for watching
you can get your hands on my book stick
a flag in it over
on amazon or on audible links to both in
the description below
thank you